This lecture is  about topic mining and analysis.
We
are going to talk about its motivation and task definition.
In this
lecture, we are going to talk about the different type of mining task.
As you see on this roadmap, we have just
covered mining knowledge
we have just
about the language namely discovery of word
associations such as paradigmatic relations
relations and syntagmatic relations.
Now, starting from this lecture,
we're going to talk about mining
another kind of knowledge, which is
content mining and trying to discover
knowledge about.
The main topics.
In the text.
And we call that topic mining and
analysis.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about its motivation and the task
definition.
So first, let's look at the concept of
topic.
So topic is something that we all
understand, I think, but it's actually
not that easy to formally define it.
Roughly speaking, topic is the main
idea discussed in text data, and you
can think of this as a theme or subject
of discussion or conversation.
It can also have different
granularities.
For example, we can talk about the
topic of a sentence.
A topic of article topic of a
paragraph, or the topics of all the
research articles in the digital
library.
So different granularities of topics
obviously have different applications.
Indeed, there are many applications
that require discovery of topics in
text and then analyze them.
Here are some examples.
For example, we might be interested in
knowing what are Twitter users talking
about today?
Are they talking about NBA sports or
talking about some international
events, etc.
Or we are interested in knowing about
the research topics.
For example, one might be interested in
knowing what are the current research
topics in data mining and how are they
different from
those five years ago. Now this involves
discovery of topics in data mining,
literatures and also we want to
discover topics in today's literature
and those in the past.
And then we can make a comparison.
We might be also interested in knowing
what do people like about some product
like iPhone 6 and what do they dislike?
And this involves discovering topics in
positive opinions about iPhone 6 and
also negative reviews about it.
Or perhaps we're interested in knowing
what are the major topics debated in
2012 presidential election?
And all these have to do is discovering
topics in texts and analyzing them, and
we're going to talk about a lot of
techniques for doing this.
In general, we can view topic as some
knowledge about the world.
So from text that we expected to
discover a number of topics and then
this topic generally provide
the description about the world and it
tells us something about the world,
about the product, about the person,
etc.
Now when we have some non-text data
then we can have more context for
analyzing the topics.
For example, we might know the time
associated with the text data or
locations where the text data will be
produced or the authors of text or the
sources of the text etc.
All such meta data or context variables
can be associated with the topics that
we discover.
And then we can use these context
variables to help us analyze patterns
of topics.
For example, looking at topics
overtime, we would be able to discover
whether there's a trending topic or
some topics might be fading away.
Similar looking at the topics in
different locations, we might know some
insights about people's opinions in
different locations.
So that's why mining topics is very
important.
Now let's look at the tasks of topic
mining and analysis.
In general, it would involve first
discovering a lot of topics.
In this case K topics.
And then we also would like to know which
topics are covered in which documents,
to what extent.
So for example in.
Document one we might see that
topic 1 is covered a lot, topic 2
and topic k are covered with a small
portion.
And other topics perhaps are not
covered.
Document 2, on the other hand,
covered topic 2
very well, but it did not cover topic
1 at all and also covers topic K to
some extent.
etc., right?
So now you can see there are generally
two different tasks or subtasks.
The first is to discover K topics from
a collection of text data.
What are these K topics?
OK, major topics in the text data.
The second task is to figure out which
documents cover which topics to what
extent.
So more formally, we can define the
problem as follows.
First, we have as input a collection of
N text documents.
Here we can denote that text
connection.
as C.
And denote a text article as di and
we generally also need to have as input
the number of topics K.
But there may be techniques that can
automatically suggest a number of
topics, but in the techniques that we
will discuss which are also the most
useful techniques, we often need to
specify a number of topics.
Now the output would then be the K
topics that we would like to discover
denoted as theater sub one through
theta sub k.
Also we want to generate the coverage
of topics in each document d sub i
and this is denoted by π sub i j and
π sub i j
is the probability of
document d sub i covering topic
theta sub j.
So obviously for each document we have
a set of such values indicate.
To what extent did the document covers
each topic.
An we can assume that these
probabilities sum to one, because a
document won't be able to cover other
topics outside the topics that we
discussed we discovered.
So now the question is how do we define
theta sub i?
How do we define the topic now?
This problem has not been completely
defined until we define what is exactly
theta.
So in the next a few lectures, we're
going to talk about different ways to
define theta.